hey guys this is dense the founders take
care and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic looking video game guru and this
is our review of Viking season 2 episode
2 and 3 yeah it's like about invasion
and I'm gonna talk about treachery so
two key words probably something one of
those two gonna be happen in each of
these yeah we finally get to see in the
third episode we get to see born old
they are in big be armed yeah was actor
Alexander Ludwig maybe somebody's
remember him from The Hunger Games the
first one he was one of the big bullies
one of them really you know supposedly
good kids in the games I'd like these
last couple episodes I think you know
season one maybe had a little slower
start I think this starts this season
starting off with more of a bang a lot
of I think we've had a battle on each
episode you know a big fight
the Vikings you know episode two finally
sailed to England we get to see some of
our first conversation with Athelstan
again to see where he is now cuz he you
know I guess the question is is he more
viking now or sees it takes place four
years later I mean right back it's four
years later did you we see you know that
that uh princess as long as long as
pregnant again again yep and she's very
jealous yeah cuz Ragnar still acting
like a kid sometimes yeah I just first
of all she kind of annoys me and then
second of all it's like how do you not
know you when you slept with him for the
first time he was cheating on his wife
right exactly so you don't expect him to
flirt with this young girl that comes by
I know it's a Canalis that he's y'all
yeah Charlie I mean he's it's too bad I
mean and it's you know going to the next
episode it's sad scene lagertha you know
getting slapped around he's a shield
Nate now I wonder to kill that dude I'm
like what you just kill him I know she's
badass and I wonder if he even knows
that about her and Buuren I think he
wants to like I don't go off and live
somewhere else he wants to his own thing
it's cool to see that he still misses
his dad you know he says he has some
respect for him yeah but I also wonder
if he has any resentment at all I'm sure
yeah I'm sure when they face each other
there might be some sort of
reconciliation but then also at the same
time resent
in terms of like even though he chose to
go with their I'm sure he still holds a
grudge that he chose this other woman
basically over his old family and I know
that you said the first reasons and what
some of your favorite parts from season
one were when they talk about like
Viking culture versus you know the
culture over in England especially now I
think we're in Wessex and I really liked
the moments when Athelstan first me to
his people I guess the monks he meets
the monks and this priest gets tortured
by King horik all these guys floki
especially who seems kind of wicked he
loves do that kind of stuff and you know
I thirst and I guess helps him out a
little bit he's like no man even four
years I don't know if he could turn him
that like no that situation you was out
of mercy but just like healing the other
Englishman right he felt bad about it
yeah but yeah he has he's turned you
know and he keeps saying that he's self
Loki that he worships Odin now and focus
like I don't think I really believe you
and I don't think so either I think he
still does you know have his faith and
his belief and still does I don't think
he wants to slaughter all of his people
no and even rat essentially what I love
about the show is like like Game of
Thrones
there's hold the whole gray area because
even Ragnar likes a pillage but he's not
as dark and as maybe twisted some other
guys like he saw a little kid in the
corner
you know only through the blanket over
the kid while his you know boys were
raiding the air because he knows that
kid I don't they kill him or her but
they might do something to him and
Ragnar didn't take you know part of the
torture either well yeah that one guy
had opened up the trap door right and I
was like okay well they got some
prisoners or hostages yeah that's the
one thing you know that's that's
fascinating about this shows we're
watching we're seeing through the
perspective of the Vikings and whatnot
as a protagonist they're not the good
guys no think about it you know if you
really think about you're like well it's
actually England is getting attacked by
these guys there is trying to defend
themselves even though they set up this
new King Akbar yeah whatever is the
quote-unquote villain right the series
he's just trying to protect I mean he's
an [ __ ] for letting his people die
but he's being attacked so of course
he's gonna
trying to fight back right I think he's
gonna be a good villain cuz what did I
think somebody described I think when it
was episode 2 I believe Allison was you
know translating a conversation and
they're asking like what's this King
like and he looked at right I said he's
like you according to these guys not
like you so I'll be curious e how that
goes yeah I like everything that's going
on and I guess got to give some credit
to Rolo cuz poor Rolo I mean he's just
like I think they showed him about four
years later he's a drunk and I'm the
living on the streets you know I guess
you've equipment of their streets over
there and I like to see he stuck up for
the family he did what his brother left
him there to do he protected his family
the best you could hear a little bit of
redemption we don't know if Ragnar is
gonna know about it or see it I'm
assuming so when he comes back but yeah
but you know at the same time it's like
wow like cuz he wanted to die yeah I
love that scene when they're you know
fighting in the town square and they had
that standoff and you can see Rolo wants
to stay maybe 1/7 honorable death he
wants to prove himself and I love that
there's some old guy next to him on the
who this character as he said Rolo I'll
tell the gods what you did today like if
anybody like he wanted somebody big look
I did the right thing I'm doing the
right thing and instead he has to go you
know to live another day he has to go in
the hills with Ragnar you know newborn
son and in siggy so what Ziggy's just
shady I don't know what she's got oh
yeah she sleeps with me horik because
she wants to get I don't know she was
power so much power somehow yeah but
she's not gonna get it with King horik
but maybe he can help her out right
she's you know try and manipulate Rollo
right no but yeah there's a lot I know
you're saying like you liked the shows I
do a little more of the political
maneuvering this show is starting to get
a little bigger it's it is it's slowly
getting bigger it's still not on the
level of like a Spartacus or Game of
Thrones right in terms of that and
political maneuvering but there is a
little bit of that you know we have what
was that jarl borg borg like with him
getting that I feel bad for I mean in
the sense of they made that agreement he
comes all the way over there ready to go
something wrong yeah and and because
hork doesn't trust him right he can't go
on the raids and I thought the whole
thing was supposed to bring them
together right and I like that they took
that time to show you're aboard like it
at his place like with his people like
if he's got married again it was a fun
moment I mean seen him you know drink
the wine and had that job with like oh I
didn't die it's not poison you know that
was I mean I like that they do give all
the characters you know some good time
you know unscreened
to you know show what they can do so I
always thought the casting was a did a
good job with casting yeah now he's come
back to carry so weird that he's like he
didn't want to attack horik but he
wanted heck Ragnar who's like not really
that responsible he was just a messenger
right yeah because he's like I didn't do
cuz I mean yeah he was just a messenger
he's like I'm sorry
this isn't the way I want to do things
but the King's the king so I got listen
to him but it's one of those things
where I think Borg was like I can't take
out porrik but I can maybe I can take
out Ragnar right because this place is
all defenseless so I mean it's gonna be
I'm gonna be curious to see how you know
what's gonna happen when Ragnar comes
back if Rollo's gonna hopefully get some
cred for what he did taking his family
what's a good how was born we know Bjorn
and lagertha are gonna end up you know
meet Ragnar again at some point like how
is that gonna happen what that's gonna
look like it's like I was gonna kill
that man that is that she's with right
now
first laughing her around there's a lot
of good things I don't know what the
whole thing is with the Sun snake in the
eye with that I don't know what all that
is that's too much prophecy for me but
there's a lot of good things coming on
this season I think it's off to a good
start only three episodes in yeah I
think they gave it last year was 9 this
is 10
they gave it one more up this is just
ten episodes sort of like Game of
Thrones thinking with yeah a nice short
and sweet let's get to the point and
then move on to the next story
alright cool alright guys so let us know
what you thought of Vikings episodes 2 &
3 of season 2 you can post your comments
below on the website fin CARICOM or on
our youtube channel think hero pro make
sure to subscribe to that okay come
check us out on Twitter talk to us about
Vikings you know if you've given if
you've seen our review and giving the
show a shot for your first time you know
let us know what you think about that
you can find us at think here oh I'm at
Griffin de and we have a Facebook page
that's facebook.com slash think hero
fans and make sure you like that page
and share our videos on Twitter and
Facebook and all the other stuff
you